welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm fair and cousins sitting in for
David Pakman today and just keeping with
what we were talking about in the first
time in the show one more discussion
about guns in the United States and this
discussion actually came from Supreme
Court Justice Clarence Thomas Clarence
Thomas is typically the quiet SCOTUS
judge he's not a guy that really likes
to go out there and talk a lot either to
the press or during actual hearings in
front of the Supreme Court but this week
Clarence Thomas decided to get a little
bit outspoken on the issue of Second
Amendment rights in the United States
and he also by speaking out Desai will
not decide it but he showed us how
little this man actually knows about
what the United States Supreme Court has
done on the issue of the Second
Amendment what happened was at the 9th
Circuit Court upheld a 10-day waiting
period in the state of California for
guns the US Supreme Court decided they
were not gonna take up the case which
means the 9th Circuit's ruling stands
and says yes California you can have
this 10-day waiting period for people
seeking to buy guns actually makes a lot
of sense right if anybody goes into a
store and says I need a gun right now
I can't wait probably not the kind of
person you want to sell a gun to right
so Clarence Thomas decides you know what
I'm speaking up I'm speaking out and
here's what he had to say the court
would take these cases because abortion
speech and the Fourth Amendment are
three of its favored rights the right to
keep and bear arms is apparently the
courts constitutional orphan so Clarence
Thomas thinks the poor little Second
Amendment is just forgotten by the
Supreme Court now this the same Supreme
Court that back in 2008 upheld a DC or
overturned I should say laws banning
handguns in Washington DC at every
possible opportunity in recent history
the United States
in court has pretty much gone in favor
of the Second Amendment of gun owners
and so for Clarence Thomas to come out
and say that the Second Amendment is the
Forgotten orphan of the Constitution you
know what I'm gonna go out on a limb
here and say that in reality probably
the third amendment is kind of the
constitutional orphan
that's not one you really hear much
about and I guarantee you most Americans
have no idea what the third amendment to
the US Constitution actually is but come
on
especially at this point with everything
that has happened I mean hell in the
last decade with guns in the United
States and the issue of gun violence and
the prevalence of these weapons of war
like ar-15s yeah something needs to be
done and if it's a 10-day waiting period
if that's the best we can get we have to
take it but keep fighting for more than
that and Clarence Thomas is lying
through his teeth at this point oh it's
the Forgotten orphan of the Constitution
that is such a crock the Second
Amendment is something that the Supreme
Court itself has allowed to be morphed
into this whole theme that Americans
have the right to own whatever kind of
gun they want even if it's something
that was specifically designed to kill
60 or 70 human beings every minute the
Supreme Court is right mm-hmm the
Supreme Court is why we're in this mess
they're the ones who did this to us they
could have many years ago said you know
what yeah the Second Amendment says the
right to bear arms but that doesn't mean
firearms that just means like swords and
knives because those counters armaments
they could have ended this long before
it started but they didn't they could
have said that no it doesn't mean that
you have the constitutional right to own
a high-capacity machine gun but they
didn't so Clarence Thomas not only does
he clearly not understand what the
Supreme Court has done with the Second
Amendment over the years but I think his
little recent
I read here shows that he should
probably go back to just staying quiet
because he has no idea what he is
talking about on this issue